yes and the Prime Minister actually
Rishi sunak has just tweeted to say that
this is a historic moment for NATO that
makes us all safer it's a bit of deja vu
to be honest on the eve of last year's
Summit in Madrid there was again a
nail-biting drama about whether or not
turkey would agree to the initial stages
of accession for not just Sweden but
Finland as well and it's again at the
11th Hour it said yes and there was this
big Fanfare about this historic moment
but here we are a year later Finland has
now joined NATO it joined the alliance a
few months ago but Sweden is still on
the outside with turkey continuing to
raise concerns about security issues
principally it's worried about Sweden's
approach to Kurdish militants that
turkey views as a threat but there was a
meeting today in Vilnius which is where
I am which is where the NATO Summit is
going to be taking place tomorrow and
Wednesday and the head of NATO he met
with the Turkish president and the
Swedish prime minister and came out this
evening with this joint statement which
said that turkey has agreed to move this
accession protocol to the Turkish
Parliament to be ratified as soon as
possible but when Jen stoltenberg was
asked what that actually means in
practice he couldn't give a concrete
date so we still are in a bit of limbo
and also thrown into the mix president
erdogan today raised the idea that
Turkish agreement to Sweden joining NATO
would hinge on whether the EU were to
open up membership for turkey to that
club and actually as part of the deal
that's just been announced tonight
Sweden has said that it will um it will
amplify its efforts to support Turkish
membership to the EU so there you go
there has been a bit of a breakthrough
which will be a relief for all the NATO
allies as they've got lots more crunchy
decisions tomorrow and Wednesday
principally around Ukraine to take place